[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin ihnen allen einen guten
abend katja stresow auch heute wieder
mit dem täglichen sport update so ist
jetzt schon gut und das haben wir unter
anderem heute für sie vorbereitet
hunger als waffe die eu
kommissionspräsidenten nennt es
beschämend wie russland ukrainisches
getreide blockiert und so
ernährungskrisen heraufbeschwört
mindestens acht bestätigte fälle für
alle die sich in deutschland mit affen
brocken infizieren empfiehlt der
gesundheitsminister drei wochen
isolation
geschlagen und erniedrigt enthüllungs
fotos aus china zeigen wie polizisten
muslimische uiguren in umerziehungslager
systematisch foltern
seit drei monaten leben wir in einer
stark veränderten welt seit exakt drei
monaten dauert der ukraine krieg an auf
dem weltwirtschaftsforum in davos war
eu-kommissionspräsident den von der
leyen russland vor auch hunger als waffe
einzusetzen
genaueres dazu gleich von unserem
reporter in der ukraine
zuvor aber anne gellinek über den
zweiten tag in davos wo es auch um die
folgekosten des krieges ging man kann
der user konferenz wirklich nicht zu
viel glamour vorwerfen statt rotem
teppich eine weiße pressspan tür aus der
die ehrengäste vor die fotografen treten
heute ursula von der leyen
eu-kommissionspräsident in sie spricht
über den geplanten wiederaufbau in der
ukraine die die eu kommission mit einer
art agentur koordinieren und am liebsten
mit geld russischer oligarchen
finanzieren würde ich betone das ist
nicht einfach aber ich finde es gebietet
einfach die gerechtigkeit dass wir alles
tun dass es auch einen beitrag russland
zum wiederaufbau der ukraine
umstritten auch die frage woher die
europäer das geld nehmen sollen und ob
gemeinsame schulden wie beim corona
wiederaufbau von next generation die
lösung sein könnten aus deutschland
kommt eine prompte absage für
deutschland muss sich klarmachen
eine anleihe an das modell next
generation eu ist für deutschland
ausgeschlossen der krieg in der ukraine
verändert auch die diskussion über den
weltweiten handel
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg warnt
in einem bemerkenswerten auftritt die
konsternierte wirtschafts elite vor
geschäften mit autoritären staaten
freiheit ist wichtiger als freihandel
der schutz unserer werte ist wichtiger
als profit ist poken
davos denkt globalisierung neu die
ukraine beherrscht auch den zweiten tag
des weltwirtschaftsforums dabei wächst
die sorge vor einer globalen
lebensmittelkrise die putin durch
bewusste blockaden verschärft auch
darauf sucht davos eine antwort
vor drei monaten also überfielen
russische truppen die ukraine kiew
konnten sie nicht einnehmen die
offensive im norden der ukraine
scheiterte seitdem konzentrieren sich
die angriffe auf den don was im osten im
süden der ukraine liegt nico live am
schwarzen meer das maritime zentrum mit
wichtigen handelshäfen weil russland sie
blockiert hungern inzwischen menschen im
nahen osten oder nordafrika und es droht
noch schlimmer zu werden aus der ukraine
johannes hano es ist derzeit wohl einer
der gefährlichsten jobs der welt bauer
in der ukraine wir sind unterwegs mit
oberleutnant von excel den ski von der
63 wir sind in der roten zone an der
südfront in der region nicolai auch bei
dem feldweg vor uns ein traktor der auf
eine mine gefahren ist der bauer ist
dabei umgekommen der soldat bewundert
den mut der bauer
ich kann nur sagen er war ein held ich
bin soldat des ukrainisch militärs die
bauern aber kämpfen an der zweiten front
der wirtschaftlichen damit die welt
nicht hungern
ein paar kilometer weiter zeigt uns der
bauern oder mir ein stück womit sie hier
auf den feldern jeden tag zu kämpfen
haben mit einem rapsfeld ein
bombenkrater ein russisches
kampfflugzeug hat seine felder
bombardieren unsere dörfer und felder
wir finden ihre bomben an orten an denen
es überhaupt kein militär gibt die mit
der ernte dieses jahr wird es wohl
schlecht aussehen die russischen truppen
würden die bauern in der region
ausrauben
wir stehen die mähdrescher und
landmaschinen sie stehen getreide und
saatgut und bringen alles nach russland
und auf die krise die ernte wird wegen
des krieges wohl deutlich geringer
ausfallen und dann ist da noch das
problem mit der aus dem vergangenen jahr
mehr als 20 millionen tonnen getreide
und andere agrarprodukte können nicht
ausgeführt werden weil die häfen in
odessa nikolajew durch die russische
marine blockiert werden die lager sind
voll und die neue ernte ist noch nicht
einmal ruiniert du in die hafen
blockaden müssen aufgehoben werden denn
es ist nicht nur unser problem es ist
ein problem für die ganze welt
seeblockade angriffe auf die ukrainische
landwirtschaft der hunger wird für
russland zur waffe in diesem krieg in
einem land das hunderte millionen
menschen weltweit mit
grundnahrungsmitteln versorgt
der ukraine krieg auch das beherrschende
thema auf der letzten station der reise
von bundeskanzler scholz nach afrika in
pretoria traf er den präsidenten
südafrikas drummer vorsah mit blick auf
den krieg gab es deutliche
meinungsverschiedenheiten
südafrika verzichtet darauf den
russischen angriff zu verurteilen durch
gemeinsamkeiten dagegen bei
energiefragen südafrika soll kohle
liefern um ausfälle aus russland
abzufedern im gegenzug hilft deutschland
beim ausbau erneuerbarer energien
die pandemie erfahrungen der letzten
zwei jahre hinterlassen ihre spuren weil
sich weltweit fälle von affen pocken
häufen herrscht verunsicherung
in europa gibt es mehr als 100 in
deutschland acht bestätigte infektionen
gesundheitsminister laut aber auch sagt
man müsse die gefahr ernst nehmen und
maßnahmen zur eindämmung ergreifen er
rechne aber mit keiner neuen pandemie
sabine kommen und kai niklasch berichten
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
muss sich nun bei einer neuen
herausforderung bewähren affen brocken
besonders verbreitet sind sie bei
männern die ungeschützten sex mit
anderen männern hatten beunruhigend sei
dass die ausbrüche international so
anders verliefen als in der
vergangenheit dennoch was wir mit den
affen brocken gerade erleben ist nicht
der beginn einer neuen pandemie von
allem was wir wissen
hat es ausbrüche diese viruserkrankung
schon sehr häufig gegeben und sie kann
durch gute kontakt nachverfolgung und
vorsicht auch gut in den griff bekommen
werden zu den symptomen gehören fieber
kopf- und muskelschmerzen und ausschlag
neu ist dass viele in europa infizierte
in letzter zeit nicht nach afrika
gereist waren die europa variante
verläuft offenbar milder und hilfreich
ist dass in den 70er jahren im westen
und 80er im osten noch gegen pocken
geimpft wurde die immunität ist gegeben
sie wird natürlich immer schwächer je
länger diese impfung her ist also die
konkret ist auch einer der person
infiziert der auch eine impfung damals
hatte also die immunität lässt natürlich
nach aber den das krankheitsgeschehen
wird abgemildert deutschland hat nun
40.000 impfdosen geordert der
bundesgesundheitsminister strich heraus
unser land befindet sich nicht am
vorabend einer pandemie
die affen brocken für uns eine neue
krankheit entsprechend viele fragen wir
haben in unserer app antworten für sie
zusammengestellt was sind die symptome
und die übertragungswege wie kann man
sich schützen und vieles mehr
es gibt eine neue empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission sie rät nun
alle kinder zwischen fünf und elf jahren
gegen das corona virus zu impfen auch
jene die schon infiziert waren eine
dosis sei ausreichend um eine
grundimmunisierung
empfehlung für kinder mit
vorerkrankungen oder kontakt zu
risikopersonen
jetzt zur innenpolitik ist es
interessant was sich nach den
landtagswahlen in schleswig-holstein und
nordrhein-westfalen tut in beiden
bundesländern wird sondiert und sowohl
im westen als auch im norden sieht nach
einer schwarz-grünen landesregierung aus
klarer wahlsieger war jeweils die cdu
die grünen hatten stark zugelegt in
schleswig-holstein könnten schon morgen
die koalitionsverhandlungen staaten
bislang gab es dort eine jamaika
koalition aus cdu grünen und fdp auch in
nrw fliegt die fdp wohl aus der
regierung auch hier könnte es bald
schwarz grün sein wir schauen mit
hermann behrendt nach kiel und beginnen
mit thomas münten in düsseldorf
sie kommen beide zu fuß wollen aber
wirken mit den demonstranten vor der tür
reden und sich gegenseitig ihre
wertschätzung beweisen nun neubauer und
henry bis heute mit großen delegationen
beim ersten sondierungstreffen in
düsseldorf
thematisch noch weit entfernt was
windkraft braunkohle und verkehr angeht
aber mit erkennbarem einigungs million
unsere partei haben unterschiedliche
schwerpunkte
das ist auch gut so ziel muss jetzt sein
auf die wesentlichen zukunftsthemen
unseres landes gemeinsame antworten zu
geben die menschen brauchen in nordrhein
westfalen eine regierung auf der höhe
der zeit wir sind dazu bereit und freuen
uns jetzt auf die gemeinsamen gespräche
bis zum wochenende soll ein erstes
papier erstellt werden auf dessen
grundlage die grünen auf einem kleinen
parteitag darüber entscheiden wollen ob
sie koalitionsverhandlungen aufnehmen
bis dahin haben beide parteien
stillschweigen vereinbart
in kiel geht es erst einmal herzlich zu
daniel günther kennt die grünen als
verlässliche partner aus jamaika zeiten
das bisherige dreierbündnis aber ist bei
den sondierungen gescheitert mit den
grünen als einzige partner und einer
satten mehrheit im rücken will günther
ehrgeizige klimaschutzziele erreichen
und mit mehr arbeitsplätzen verbinden
aber auch eigene akzente setzen etwa
beim ausbau der infrastruktur der
inneren sicherheit oder beim thema
landwirtschaft wir haben 43,4 prozent
geholt und das muss ich auch in einem
koalitionsvertrag natürlich dort
wiederfinden und das ist der grund warum
wir jetzt in die verhandlungen auch
guten mutes und selbstbewusst reingehen
deine günther plant das morgen schon die
koalitionsverhandlungen beginnen er will
schnell mit schwarz grün zum ziel kommen
der zins hauptstadtstudio zuschlag und
alain bernard und aller sowohl in
schleswig holstein als auch nordrhein
westfalen stehen die zeichen als auch
schwarz-grün welche bedeutung hat das
jetzt für die regierende ampel koalition
in berlin ja das muss die liberalen und
die spd durchaus beunruhigend dass union
und grüne da so schnell zusammenfinden
landespolitik ist zwar nicht gleich
bundespolitik aber ich glaube man kann
doch zwei dinge ableiten aus dem was man
jetzt in den sondierungen oder vor den
sondierungen sieht das eine ist dass die
fdp ist nicht schafft das selbst
gesteckte ziel zu erreichen sich
unverzichtbar zu machen für koalition
selbst da nicht wo sie sich nach eigenem
empfinden in der regierung eigentlich
ganz gut hervorgetan hat und die spd
schafft es auf der anderen seite nicht
der ampel oder dem modell ampel so große
strahlkraft zu verleihen dass es die
grünen davon abhält ihre neuen
machtoptionen auch zu nutzen und das
ganze wird hier in berlin sicherlich den
profilierungs druck auf spd und fdp
erhöhen und damit das gemeinsame
regieren in der dreier konstellation
ampel nicht erleichtern chuck und danke
nach berlin wir schauen jetzt auf eine
andere partei nach schlechten
wahlergebnissen und viel streit in der
partei sucht die linke den neuanfang
neben der amtierenden parteivorsitzenden
wissler bewerben sich jetzt auch zwei
männer um die doppelspitze zum einen der
europaabgeordnete martin schulte waren
und zum anderen kündigte auch der
leipziger bundestagsabgeordnete sören
pellmann seine bewerbung an er wolle von
einer sich selbst bekämpfen den linken
zurück zu einer kämpferischen linken
sagte er in berlin schon
lange wehrt sich china gegen vorwürfe
von menschenrechts-organisationen sie
werfen der regierung in peking vor mehr
als eine million regieren und andere
muslimische minderheiten in sogenannten
umerziehungslager festzuhalten und zur
zwangsarbeit zu nötigen die abwehr
dieser anschuldigungen dürfte wohl noch
schwieriger werden denn es sind
massenhaft neue beweise aufgetaucht
fotos reden behörden anweisungen die
schwere menschenrechtsverstöße
dokumentieren ulf röller aus peking
es sind grausame bilder die zeigen wie
brutal chinas machthaber die uiguren
unterdrücken sie belegen tausendfach die
massen internierung 'nen und kulturelle
vernichtung der muslimischen minderheit
die bilder stammen von 2018 aus einem
umerziehungslager ingenieur adrian sense
hat die daten anonym zugespielt bekommen
erforscht seit jahren zum schicksal der
uiguren die daten belegen halt wirklich
ohne jegliche zweifel
die gefängnis artigen natur dieser
umerziehungslager durch die die
dokumente die halt genau sagen wie die
lager zu bewachen sind welche waffen die
polizei benutzt in tianjin soll es mehr
als 300 lager geben eine million
menschen die muslimischen minderheiten
angehören soll china in den letzten
jahren interniert haben die dokumente
gäben den opfern ein gesicht
die internationale gemeinschaft hat die
moralische verpflichtung diesen
völkermord zu stoppen es gibt keinen
grund mehr zu schweigen denn hier liegen
neue beweise vor
die un menschenrechtskommissarin hat
sich mit dem chinesischen außenminister
heute getroffen der hatte nichts klar zu
stellen sondern spricht von lügen von
anti chinesischen kräften aus
ministerien bernburg fordert nun
aufklärung
für mich wichtig dass diese vorwürfe von
chinesischer seite die seit langem
bekannt sind dass ich dazu positioniert
wird china will nicht dass die welt
diese bilder sieht während wir die
dokumente abfilmen verschwindet die
seite wir vermuten der chinesische staat
steckt dahinter
in china hat es auch vergangenes jahr
tausende hinrichtungen gegeben weltweit
erneut die meisten das berichtet amnesty
international
zahlen dazu hält die regierung geheim
ebenso die in nord korea und vietnam
tatsächlich dokumentiert hat ms die
mindestens 5 179 vollstreckte
todesurteile in 18 staaten gegenüber dem
vorjahr ein anstieg um 20 prozent auch
wegen gelockerter corona maßnahmen die
meisten erfassten hinrichtungen gab es
in iran ägypten saudi arabien und syrien
die museen ehemaliger kolonial länder
sind voll mit schätzen die unterdrückten
völkern oft mit gewalt geraubt wurden
lange ist diese geschichte verdrängt
worden aber jetzt sind andere zeiten
angebrochen auch in berlin die
bundesregierung hat sich vor einem jahr
zu den verbrechen der kolonialzeit
bekannt und beginnt jetzt damit raubt
zurück zu geben auch an namibia dem
ehemaligen deutsch-südwestafrika nadia
nasa dazu ein traditioneller kopfputz
der herero frauen historischer schmuck
werkzeuge puppen darunter auch objekte
aus namibischen königshäusern kunstwerke
von unschätzbarem wert sollen nach mehr
als 100 jahren zurück in ihre heimat des
ob die kritiker diese objekte wurden
namibia weg genau ohne dass wir namibia
zugestimmt hätten deswegen ist diese
initiative sehr wichtig aber es ist nur
ein erster schritt auf einem langen weg
ist
der long way to go von einem namibischen
expertenteam wurden in berlin 23
kulturell besonders wertvolle objekte
ausgewählt aus insgesamt 1400 und
zusammen mit deutschen expertinnen nach
ihrer herkunft untersucht einige davon
sind beutekunst aus der kolonialzeit im
damaligen deutsch südwestafrika
regierten die kolonialherren mit
brutaler härte
aufständische herero und nama wurden zu
zehntausenden ermordet kulturelle
schätze geplündert heute ist der
großteil der afrikanischen kunst werke
im besitz europäischer museen das
ethnologische museum berlin will mit dem
namibia projekt da vorreiter sein es hat
sich im gesamten bewusst seiner
gesellschaft der politik der
kultureinrichtung was verändert es gibt
auch eine erwartungshaltung der
öffentlichkeit begeben die dinge die in
einem klaren unrechts kontexten zurück
jetzt werden die objekte also nach
namibia reisen offiziell erst nur
geliehen wahrscheinlich bleiben sie für
immer ein kleiner anfang
wir machen mit dem sport weiter und
katja stresow und fußball gestern ging
es ja um 7 und zittern bei hertha heute
ums aufwarten man hört immer noch das
aufatmen in berlin denn die berliner die
hertha bsc gewann das relegations
rückspiel beim hamburger sv mit 2 0 und
bleibt damit in der bundesliga doch ruhe
kehrt beim hauptstadtklub dadurch nicht
ein im gegenteil geschäftsführer fredi
bobic erwartet ordentliche turbulenzen
und personalquerelen
ende gut alles gut was gestern außer wie
eine klassenfahrt war sportliche
überlebenskampf härter bleibt in der
ersten liga dank kurzzeit trainer
das war ein rundherum professioneller
auftritt der mannschaft die von anfang
an leidenschaftlich gekämpft hat der
ligaverbleib geschafft aber jetzt haben
sie eine fußball großbaustelle erste
bundesliga das bleibt in berlin wir
freuen uns einfach und ich weiß ab
morgen für was ich arbeite immer geld
ist weg der manager muss erstmal einen
neuen trainer finden er muss
persönlichkeit mitbringen und er muss
das feuer auch mitbringen förder bisher
alles zu geben sich kometen auf dann auf
auf den weg den wir gehen dann auch den
harten weg den wir gehen ohne den
investor wird es nicht gehen der
präsident gegenbauer ist soeben nach 14
jahren an der vereinsspitze
zurückgetreten hätte gestern auf den
knien aber immer noch da jetzt wollen
sie wieder aufstehen
während hertha also noch einen trainer
sucht ist der vfl wolfsburg nun auch
offiziell fündig geworden wie schon
gemutmaßt übernimmt niko kovac den
posten bei den wölfen geplant bis 2025
und die tsg hoffenheim wird künftig von
andré breitenreiter trainiert sein
vertrag läuft bis 2024
die deutsche eishockey
nationalmannschaft hat ihr letztes
vorrundenspiel gegen die schweiz mit
drei zu vier verloren durch den
schönsten treffer des spiels von
matthias plachta zum 3 3 rettete sich
deutschland immer ins penalty schießen
da sorgte der schweizer riad dann aber
für die entscheidung das deutsche team
nun gruppenzweiter im viertelfinale über
morgen wartet entweder olympiasieg auf
finnland oder der zwölfmalige
weltmeister tschechien
tennisprofi angelique kerber hat sie
erstmals ein erstmals seit vier jahren
wieder in die zweite runde bei den
french open gekämpft gegen magdalena
frech aus polen hier oben im bild wer
die deutsche zwei matchbälle ab und
gewann am ende mit 2 6 6 3 7 5
von morgen sind unter anderem andrea
petkovic und alexander zverev drin
vielen dank katja in sachen wetter so
viel im norden und süden stärker bewölkt
mit schauern sonst oft freundlich mehr
hat gleich christa thoben unsere ein
schaltempfehlung für 21 45 das heute
journal mit marietta slomka im gespräch
mit ursula von der leyen schönen dank
schönen abend und bis bald morgen
begrüßt hier an dieser stelle barbara
hahlweg wir sagen machen sie es gut
[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zum wetter
heute abend das war ja recht wechselhaft
und windig heute und das geht in einer
strammen westströmung auch jetzt erstmal
so weiter und das wird auch noch immer
ein bisschen kühler heute nacht meist
einstellige werte zwischen 6 bis 12 grad
in der eifel
da kann es auch zum beispiel um die 3
grad werden insgesamt aber meist trocken
die nach nur zwischen den bayerischen
wald und den alpen regnet es weiter da
kamen seit dienstagnacht ja auch schon
einiges an regen vom himmel und so ist
es morgen vormittag hier im südosten
auch stärker bewölkt wie der regen geht
aber so langsam in kurze schauer über
und zieht etwas abschauen und zwar auch
gewittrige gibt es noch im küstenumfeld
vor allem gegen abend lebt der wind aus
südwest noch wieder deutlich auf
dazwischen haben wir einen streifen vom
südwesten bis nach brandenburg in dem es
meist trocken und vor allem vormittags
auch noch recht sonnig ist und in genau
diesem streifen erreichen den morgen 20
bis 24 grad ansonsten haben wir 16 bis
20 grad morgen die gleiche temperatur
spanne erwartet uns dann auch am
feiertag an christi himmelfahrt 16 bis
24 grad richtung süden immer
freundlicher im norden dann doch recht
stark bewölkt mit einigen schauern und
windig mit stürmischen böen an der see
aus west am freitag und am samstag geht
es dann so windig und eben haft
wechselhaft weiter dazu wird es auch
noch etwas kühler am samstag nur noch 14
bis 20 grad